Transcriptor: Evangelina Ledesma
Revisor: Yasmin Klär
Alguna vez pensaste ¿qué rol ocupamos
los estudiantes en las ciudades?
Es una pregunta poco común, pero estoy
seguro que todos tenemos una respuesta.
Déjame contarte una experiencia para que
juntos lleguemos a una conclusión.
Mi nombre es Facundo, soy estudiante de
Relaciones Internacionales y junto a un
equipo de estudiantes de arquitectura,
ambiente y sociología, participamos de un
proyecto para reinventar una parte
de la Ciudad de Buenos Aires.
Balvanera Sur, un barrio con casi 20000
habitantes y más de 100 años de historia.
Nuestro objetivo fue atender las
necesidades de los vecinos y al mismo
tiempo rediseñar el barrio para que
sea más ecológico y sustentable.
Los pedidos de los habitantes son
principalmente más espacios verdes,
seguridad y oferta cultural.
Desde nuestra parte queríamos disminuir la
contaminación producida principalmente
por los vehículos al interior del barrio.
Nuestra primera idea fue peatonalizar
algunas de sus calles para que no
circulen autos y así bajar la emisión
de gases de efecto invernadero.
Pero nos dimos cuenta que eso afectaría a
las principales actividades económicas
del barrio, que son los estacionamientos
y los talleres mecánicos.
Aún así encontramos una solución:
ensanchar las veredas.
De esta manera podemos reducir la cantidad
de vehículos que circulan y
aumentar el espacio para que la gente
pueda caminar más cómoda.
Los habitantes de Balvanera Sur también
necesitan más espacios verdes, ya que el
barrio tiene solamente una plaza.
Entonces buscamos un lugar
donde construir otra.
Nos encontramos con que todo el
barrio estaba construido.
No había espacio, o al menos
eso fue lo que creimos.
Después de varios recorridos nos
encontramos con un lugar ideal, un pasaje
ubicado al lado de uno de los lugares
más icónicos de la zona.
Y así acá se ubicaría la plaza del Pasaje.
Balvanera está ubicada
en medio de tres lugares muy
concurridos de la ciudad.
El Congreso, la autopista y
una terminal de trenes.
Al ser un lugar de paso, la gente no suele
detenerse, generando una sensación
de inseguridad, caída de la actividad
comercial y hasta abandono de viviendas.
Por eso pensamos en que la solución está
en hacer que Balvanera tenga calles
vibrantes, llenas de vida, que inviten a
todos a caminar y disfrutar del lugar.
De esta manera, generando mayor actividad,
mejoraríamos la sensación de seguridad.
Pero ¿cómo lo haríamos?
Hace más de 100 años, Buenos Aires recibió
a miles de inmigrantes que venían
principalmente de España,
Italia y Francia.
Por eso, al caminar por Balvanera uno
puede encontrarse con arquitectura
francesa, clubes asturianos
y hasta una escuela vasca.
Con tanta riqueza cultural creemos que
Balvanera sólo puede crecer
gracias a su propia historia.
También planteamos la idea de instalar
paneles solares en los techos
de las escuelas, autoabasteciéndolas y
brindando energía no contaminante
al barrio. Y para reducir aún
más la contaminación,
creemos que reubicando las paradas de los
colectivos a las avenidas
podemos alcanzar más tranquilidad,
menos tráfico y aire más limpio.
Con nuestras ideas propusimos más de dos
mil trescientos metros cuadrados
de espacio verde,
una plaza nueva.
Atendimos la cuestión de la seguridad
y hasta encontramos la manera
de alcanzar el desarrollo
económico del barrio.
Pero no vine a contarte solamente
cómo reinventamos un barrio.
Vine a contarte lo que aprendimos, y es
que si bien como estudiantes somos parte
de la dinámica de una ciudad, usar el
transporte público, movernos,
asistir a clases,
somos actores activos.
Por eso aprendimos que tenemos
la oportunidad de aplicar
nuestros conocimientos
en el lugar en el que vivimos.
Se estima que en el año 2030 y 2050 más
del 70 por ciento de la población mundial
va a vivir en centros urbanos, y por eso,
como estudiantes y jóvenes,
tenemos la responsabilidad
de pensar en un futuro sostenible.
Y qué mejor que hacerlo hoy
desde nuestras ciudades.
Aprendimos que con lo que estudiamos
tenemos herramientas que nos permiten
mejorar la calidad de vida de la gente.
Así fue cómo comprendimos qué rol
ocupamos los estudiantes
en nuestras ciudades.
Nuestro rol, mi rol y tu rol
es ser parte activa de
la construcción de nuestro futuro.
Por eso te pregunto: ¿Te animas a sumarte?